Avengers in game is officially out on
digital to own so happy Avengers end
game day how's it going everybody it's
Warren and you can now buy Avengers
in-game to own for yourself on digital
and with the digital release as well as
the blu-ray release that is going to be
coming out a little bit later on we're
going to be getting a ton of commentary
from the directors from the producers
from Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios will be getting deleted scenes
and just be learning a lot more about
Avengers in game as this release comes
out and I'll be doing a lot of videos
breaking down everything we learned so
if you're not subscribed to my channel
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on anything and also be sure to
subscribe so you can enter my giveaway
at 500,000 subscribers I'm picking a
winner to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
I'll talk more about the giveaway at the
end so as you all prepare to watch
Avengers in game and as we all prepare
to learn a lot more about the movie
Kevin Feige has recently come out and
stated who he thinks is the strongest
Avenger now this has been quite the
debate for some time now is that the
Hulk is it Thor is it Doctor Strange is
it the Scarlet Witch who is the
strongest avenger strongest avenger
strongest Avenger Point Break voice
activation required
well Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios has come out in a recent
interview and said which avenger could
have defeated fan o's single-handedly by
themself Kevin Feige in an interview
about Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness let it slip who he thinks
could be the strongest Avenger
he said Wanda Maximoff who of course is
the Scarlet Witch who is probably near
the upper echelons of power I contend
she would have taken down Thanos if he
hadn't called the army it was done so
her being The Scarlet Witch now as
Lizzie said on stage in a full sort of
unn
power-based way coming into dr. strange
movie that is too hero's coming together
in a fun way
so Kevin Feige just revealed that the
Scarlet Witch is in fact the strongest
Avenger because she could have taken
down Thanos by herself in fact we almost
solved that happen in Avengers endgame
in fact the Scarlet Witch would have
killed Thanos like Kevin Feige said it
was done until Fanus ordered a raid fire
making his army launch missiles at the
entire battlefield and it is safe to say
that she would have definitely killed
him if it wasn't for the missiles in
fact even in avengers endgame she was
able to hold fan o's off with one hand
while the other one was destroying the
mine stone and vision every other
avenger has fought vanos one-on-one for
the most part in some way or another the
Hulk Iron Man Captain America Doctor
Strange they all fought Thanos and lost
now granted Doctor Strange knew what he
had to do in order for the Avengers to
win but even out of all those scenarios
it seems like if Doctor Strange was
strong enough to kill thanos he just
would have simply killed him and then
that would have been the end of the
story so out of all of the Avengers that
fought Thanos it is the Scarlet Witch
who was able to almost kill him and it
is the Scarlet Witch who is definitely
the strongest avenger so let me know
what you think about this do you think
the Scarlet Witch is the strongest
Avenger or do you think another Avengers
the strongest let me know who you think
is the strongest Avenger and let me know
why you think they're the strongest in
the comments down below and don't forget
to comment with your favorite superhero
or villain like this video and be
subscribed to my channel so you can
enter my giveaway at 500,000 subscribers
I'll be giving away an Xbox one or ps4
the winner gets to choose and I'll also
still be giving away some Marvel Legends
items as well also don't forget to
follow me on Twitter and Instagram and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof